all right jessica and robert yes
jessica and robert where did you guys
grow up where are you from originally
we're from new york originally um i'm
from the bronx and she's from upstate
messina yeah uh
we we got we met in florida yeah um
a long time ago been there 18 years
uh you've been together 18 years yes yes
i needed oh you've been homeless uh
about seven
and um
how we met was crazy um it was in
florida
and uh she was painting on that
walgreens
and i came up to her and she had a black
guy her ex-boyfriend beat her up she was
panhandling yeah flying sign or whatever
and um her boyfriend just beat her up
and he went to jail whatever um so i
said why all y'all pretty pretty white
girls give all y'all get with these
busted ass crackers they want to put
their hands on the beautiful woman like
yourself
and i let it sink in for a couple
seconds and i said that fact you were
you're with me from here on out and
and she's like just awestruck and from
there
ever since
and but then yeah
right yeah yeah then i put a 10-year
prison bid and
uh
i stuck with him she stuck with me for a
whole 10 years i was in prison put a
thousand dollars on his books every
month no
that was expensive but
then uh we was crackheads back then
i was i was a prostitute i was telling
my ass for crack and she was paneling
and stuff oh really it was honestly i
was honest with her about what i used to
do yeah and stuff and um i never did it
i never did it it was just not my thing
i could make it when the other one you
were the prostitute not her yeah
right that's a switch yeah
yeah but he was always honest so yeah
tell me about your childhoods you uh uh
my childhood uh i grew up and my mom was
a stripper and a crackhead
and um
i was in
group homes and hospitals sexually
assaulted well before that i was
sexually assaulted by my mom's boyfriend
who would uh when my mom was at work i'd
come home from school like a bad report
would put me on in the corner and maybe
kneel on cheese graters until she got
off work
and then there's a new york new york cps
took me away from my mom
and put me in group homes and hospitals
and from 10 years old to 18 i was in
that
and when i got out um
[Music]
i went to the army got kicked out the
army
and
that's basically it my life was real
fast you know
drugs were in your yeah drugs are my
main thing i've been doing drugs since i
was uh
still like 13 years old
and you you saw that with your mom yeah
i saw my mom and
i always told myself i was never gonna
do that but as years went on you know
the pressures of life got to me you know
and
my grandma grandpa died when i was 10
and that's when i started using drugs
was your dad in your life what was your
dad no i never had a father
mom had my mom had boyfriends and sugar
daddies in their life but
you know so
jessica tell me about your childhood um
well mine was actually a pretty good
childhood except for i got molested by
my dad when i was young
and
you know and
that led to drugs now but as growing up
i was i had a pretty good childhood my
mom wasn't a mom but she you know just
throw me money just to make me happy
whatever
and um
i just did any normal kid things until i
was about 16 and then
you know i lost my virginity i started
partying i
did a whole bunch of stuff that i
shouldn't but anyways um
yeah
i wasn't in like um
i graduated high school
um
i don't know i guess i had a pretty good
life but
but being molested by your dad
but that that's what age did that happen
three
three yeah
i no longer talk to him he's not a part
of my life i just choose not to because
it's just easier i don't have to relive
the memories
you know that
you go on for a while or just one time
um until i was about five
and then i got removed from his house
did he get caught
um i
told somebody at school
what was going on
so
you don't speak to your father anymore
no i don't
and he actually almost died and he has
crohn's disease he's not doing very well
but
i just choose not to talk to him
so you you've been homeless
with robert for the last seven years yes
and you guys have been together for 18.
yes
we hadn't we had an apartment and we had
we had all the things a normal person
would have
and then every ever since like our dog
got sick the dog got sick and then
that's how we lost our problem because
we lived in malibu we had a um basically
paid for a walk-in closet you know
4 500 a month and i was getting in um
[ __ ] inheritance from my grandpa
and stuff and
i was spending all day on drugs and
stuff and then my dog got sick and then
i had to get my dog save my dog's life
instead of
paying rent and then landlord had no
mercy on us so that's when we became
homeless
when we came out here we didn't use we
never used fat we use fentanyl now
um
no when we came out here we first used
christmas yeah no we wish crack we must
crack kids and we got sober and then we
started for six months six months and
then went to vegas and got messed up
there then came out here we uh oh vegas
was fun
vegas was fun
you know what they say what happens in
vegas states in vegas what was fun about
vegas i was i was catching people like
like these people somebody gave us 200
who does that they don't even know who
we are
they said they said they wanted some
black and i'm like what's that we didn't
even know what that was and then i found
out what it was and i said okay i can
get that for you and then they gave me
two dollars i told jessica come on let's
go i said wait right here to do it and
booked it climbing down the walls like
spiderman yeah climbing down the parking
the parking lot wall and stuff it was an
event i broke my wrist in that process
but
um
then we came out here and we got we got
we did crystal
and what that was kind of scary i mean
that was that was fun but
because um
it was something it opened up like
doorways in your mind you know like that
normal people don't see like you know me
and her seen this i mean her seeing
puppies in the clouds
we've seen a ghost on the end of the
pier at the end of the walkway in a
little beach i think the ghost might be
real though because
we're not sleeping for five days right
yeah yeah we saw the exact same thing at
the exact same time
i i think the crystal might have had a
pretty good
part of it but then um
we got
we got tired of that and then um that
was
i moved to black i was doing heroin i
was keeping it from her and uh
she walked in on the bathroom and he
went out she said what are you doing she
she kept seeing me going in out the
bathroom ever so often me coming out
like no i know forever
and so one time she kicked in the
bathroom door and seen me shooting up
and said she said what are you doing i
want some of that and i said no i said
what i said i said what does it feel
like like what does it make you do
and
me being the curious person that i am i
wanted to try it and that was a bad idea
no that was that was that was the
beginning of an avalanche yeah
yeah so so drugs have been a huge part
of your life yes big part pretty much
the whole ride yeah do you ever see
yourselves getting off of it yes i see
myself
so i hope for her because she has it
worse than me fentanyl is way harder
than crackdown yeah
how would you compare the three big
drugs
um cracking down fentanyl fentanyl is
like
it takes away
every problem you ever have it makes you
go into your own today's world you know
you're not off you feel good
and
um crack
it just keeps you going you know and
then just like you gotta have you do
anything for it like me
in daytona beach florida i was a
prostitute
and uh that's what had me doing i was
doing it for the drug not for the
pleasures but for the drug you know
and uh i was gay for pain basically and
then i do gave you know well it was long
sleep
um
uh crystal
when i started doing crystal that opened
up my artistic abilities to draw made me
an artist you know i mean because it's
just
that's my favorite thing to do is draw
so
i started like drawing this demonic
stuff where like skulls demons snakes
you know stuff like that
and uh
so
i say for for me crack was major a major
weight loss for me because i was always
big
and when i started smoking crack i was
300 pounds and then i dropped to like
i'd say 150 175 in six months
and then i dropped another 20 or 30
pounds on top of that so like i got
thinner and thinner and thinner you know
and i'm like oh this thing's like an
overnight diet it's you know yeah and we
had some we had some fun times on crack
though like uh somebody would give us
somebody would want some crack right and
i was like yeah okay give me give me
money or
stay i'll be feeding and i'd beat
somebody up take their money or [ __ ]
leave them at the trap house and for
hours and hours that's why i'm smoking
this stuff up and stuff
uh
what else i did fentanyl for me i guess
would be
it's hard i'm not gonna lie it's fun
though it was fun it was fun it's really
hard to like we have a lot of problems
with it we're always you know accusing
each other of who's doing what the last
hit or this yeah and it's just it's
putting a toll on our relationship where
do you guys stay now we stay uh
on figaro on eighth right there at the
corner where the bank is right there in
the tent yeah the police want us out of
there so
i don't know what to do what do you
think of this lifestyle you've got for
yourselves i want to go inside i want to
go outside i don't want to be i want to
be normal again though
i mean magic room key kind of
they don't do nothing for us like they
just bypassed us and although i do like
you know to get high and feel the that
adrenaline and stuff like that but it
would be great when we're inside yeah
i'm 40 years old and i'm trying to get i
want to get my last years doing the
right thing you know what's the worst
thing about living on the streets
not having a shower yeah that or dealing
with the crazy [ __ ] that when
you're sleeping they go on in
stuff and hover over you when you're
sleeping that's scary
i actually actually had somebody come in
our unzip our tent come in our tent take
my phone or was it your phone it was
your phone
my phone in my pocket out of his pocket
and still no they didn't take her dope
took their money they took them away
but that's that's scary to know that you
have somebody like creeping over top of
you they could do anything to me or him
you know what i mean actually that
happens on an everyday basis and you
don't even know because you're so so
nodded out and and
don't you know
you're out i guess i could be nodded out
for three four hours
so so living on the streets for so long
like this you must have some crazy
stories yeah i do i got some really
diving twists and dimension stories so
you tell me i um
there was the time where i was standing
on the corner of a1a
and i was hustling you know trying to
get money selling you know costume or
whatever this is daytona yeah they
totally beach yeah and uh this guy in
the red corvette picks me up his name is
scott carroll i still remember his name
he was like a former mayor of daytona
beach
and he's old
so he takes me back to his house right
like he's like make yourself a home you
know be comfortable right now all i see
is these chucky dolls everywhere i mean
and their hands their arms are missing
on each dollar their arms are missing
and so we get to the bed and whatever
right
and
he's like
here he hands me an arm a fist of a
chucky doll and he says i want you to
plug me with it
right so i'm doing that
and so he says here take a hit of crack
here and then you just tuck it high like
that and stuff it
and uh did that for about 30 minutes and
then um he told me to tie him up and
then
beat him and i was like i was like
really you want to go in grt so i did
that and uh
and that that happened
i mean at first i was nervous but then i
got into it and i started beating on him
and he's like oh yeah oh yeah and he
started struggling
his thick and then he busted and then
after that he gave me like
he gave me uh
80 bucks and i was like 80 bucks for all
this work i busted sweat i said no
you're gonna give me you're gonna give
me your wallet
and and um i need to get into
altercation with him i took his car his
wallet
all that's with it i drained his atm i
changed his account
crashed his car
and then uh
went on to the next the next trek
um
it was on the beach
and uh beach patrol pulled up to this
old
this old
guy giving me head his mouth was buried
in my
his mouth was buried in my crotch
and uh
and
i was sitting there hitting the pipe
whatever and um
it was
yeah i didn't know what i was talking
about for pay that's gotta be gay for
pay it's gonna be a strange life right
yeah it's funny i mean to me it was
funny at first and then it became like
an everyday chore
yeah but uh
you know florida lord of florida
is where it's at you know i used to be a
stripper out there in uh
[Music]
um
the bar called it's called uh
tuna tulips tulips it's called tulips
and uh two lips two lips two lips yeah
two lips sorry there's a bar out there
it's a it's a bisexual bar
and uh they used to pay guys they used
to give you a viagra
to take before you get on stage
and so you know your [ __ ] your junk your
junkies like
and then you just dance and keep guys
you know the guys touching and stuff and
all weird stuff
and uh
he was a chippendale i was tripping down
and i met i met a sugar mama
i met an old lady that she lived out in
uh hollywood and
yeah
uh
came out here and lived out here for a
while they went back got extracted back
actually but uh
kind of funny how it's dangerous though
i mean i got myself in a couple
situations where
you know i didn't think i was gonna make
it home alive because uh this one black
dude he picked me up
and he said i'm gonna he said at
midnight i'm gonna kill you
and he had me he had me chained up he's
like he's in the s m whatever
and i was like uh that's the name he
said don't worry just put him on your
back so okay i was doing i'm doing
everything i could for the drug you know
and um
so anyway he told me he beat he was
beating me and i felt like okay i was a
trick
because that's what i used to be doing
but uh he uh
had when when when the clock when it was
11 58
i'm like damn i i've he had a lock on
this house where the key was on the
inside
so i'm thinking i'll [ __ ] i'm done
so um
he uncuffed me at 11 57 i still remember
this and there was a uh
a marble
based like uh art art thing
and i grabbed and i tried i tried to
smack him in the head with it but it
didn't phase him
and he said i just told you this is
scary so you wouldn't do this no more
because you'll know what kind of crazy
stuff you run into here when you're
doing selling your body you know there's
a lot a lot of male prosthetists get
killed out there and stuff yeah i mean
is it a try i mean it's such a dangerous
lifestyle i don't think every every
every date ends up being dangerous in
one way or another right yeah it seems
there's a lot of weird things you know
you gotta do for for that money you know
but uh is it an attraction to the chaos
and drama or is it i think i think it's
attracting the chaos and drama yeah i
mean i loved i loved
living my life on that that very brink
of
death and life you know
but
uh
not me because i didn't know if he was
coming home with me or not how do you
feel as his partner knowing he's out
there doing that um
didn't bother me really that much
because he was he was honest you know i
was bringing him home he never lied to
me yeah
but one time we're using condoms
yeah i usually i shopped up all the time
i remember one time his ex-girlfriend
mona she's a biker [ __ ] and she sent me
a [ __ ] a [ __ ] shot right she's like 90
years old
i was like is this her nasty [ __ ] with
his [ __ ]
uh it had a rose tattoo on it and she
she's like come over and [ __ ] me it's
okay bring her and uh
i was like okay let's go let's get her
money and put her ring on my finger with
her money
i'm down
i had a lot of people out there like
that because i couldn't stand her so
yeah
but um one day i woke up and i told her
well after i got out of prison for doing
10 years
i said jessica we need to leave florida
and uh go back to new york's little one
tickets already she had plane tickets
already waiting for us and
because florida was my big downfall you
know out there you get in trouble one
time
it's a revolving door constantly you got
them getting locked up three strings
yeah i had i was down to my third strike
so we left florida and ever since then
i've been cool without going to jail you
know not not messing with the gay
lifestyle no more i've made a promise to
her
but we went back in september to see his
mom and then
not this september but last year
and then we left in october yeah and
then she passed away
in january in january that's when i
that's when i tried to kill myself with
xanax and i just found out that you
cannot kill yourself on xanax
it was really weird because like
his his mom died january 6th we didn't
find out until the 19th but on the 8th
of january she came in like a wave
because she liked ocean life and waves
and whales and stuff and she said robbie
i'm sorry i love you yeah and that was
on the 8th and we didn't find until find
out till january 19th two days before my
birthday
so that's kind of that's that's creepy
you know that not creepy but
it's cool that he has that vibe with his
mom that you know
he can get that
what's what's been the best part is it
parts of this lifestyle for you
the lack of responsibility has got to be
nice right yeah yeah no no paying bills
that's great um because all your all
your money goes on drugs but
i mean
sometimes
we had a kid it was a stillborn uh it
died came out dead obviously
uh that's
when i started doing like real heavy
heavy heavy drugs you know like
um popping pills and
trying to say i'm starting doing xanax i
picked up another habit
uh
then
i just kept
i was doing like a limited amount
and now i just i just when that happens
whatever i do whatever just to get high
oh and not to mention um i've died five
times off at night in my arms and i had
to bring her back you guys
i have five times yeah in my arms yeah
how about you no never i died once and i
we were living in clover city and he
snuck out and came downtown and i had no
idea until he came home with the the
patches on his ekg and he said that i
died and i was like what it was i would
have never known you know i left her in
there
i left her in a tent and i went down to
the dope and uh some dude gave me this
cap with this black stuff and they said
it was it was heroin but it was like
dark as dark as that like ace of spade
and it was milky like like dark like
thick and so i drew it up and i shot it
i shot a little bit and i said oh man
this stuff is good and that stood out
i said damn this is too good and boop
and i fell out right there and then the
office building across the street
seen it and called 9-1-1 and i woke up
to a paramedics like shocking me with
the paddles and stuff that was crazy
what do you worry about now what are you
afraid of what's up my uh my mom passed
away last year you know i mean and um
i have i had my family runs heart
problems
my family my family a lot of heart
problems run
and uh i just recently found out that i
have heart problems and uh
that's scary because i don't want to die
you know
you know i'm trying i'm trying to get
trying to do good and trying to get back
you know i mean
[Music]
jessica what about you what do you worry
about
um
probably overdosing
you know i i
i don't want to die i just want to
forget about my problems you know
and
you never know when your card's gonna be
up with that drug
or anything
you know you can walk out and get hit by
a bus but
but what do you think most people don't
understand about drug addiction
that they don't understand
i think i think it's the way that the
drug grips you and it makes you want to
do things to to get the drug you know
like people don't know what it's like to
be
in um if they've never been in your
shoes they don't know period like when i
was in crack i used they used to call me
a rock monster you know
spoke when i'm coming down off crack i
was like oh man i need to get some uh
and just it was like something i was
controlling my body to do that to get
dope
so
[Music]
you guys have friends yeah we got lots
of friends
um some are friends some are
acquaintances
uh
a lot of i i have very few enemies
yeah he's pretty well known out here and
pretty great
respected uh i earned my keep you
know what are your biggest regrets my
biggest regrets
uh
starting fentanyl doing fentanyl
and uh
being a bad kid to my mom
when i was younger
because she's just what what regrets do
you have um
i don't see my mom as much
you know she lives in new york and
like i don't see her i haven't seen her
in like what seven years seven years and
that's a long time because i used to go
to her house every day do you still talk
to your family i talk to my mom
not as much anymore because i'm more
into drugs but
um no once a week
if you had your lives to live all over
again what would you
have done differently
i would never came to schedule
me serious yeah no i would never i don't
know that's a hard one um
i've never started drugs probably
like if i know what i know now and what
it's going to do on the long run and
what is you know on your body the
emotional stress and stuff it puts on us
everything that baby
is a big reason because i think that has
a lot to do with the drugs i was doing
drugs still
and i just would have changed it you
know i wouldn't have done them
how do you think living on the streets
has changed you guys
i think it's changed us a lot because
i think personally he's made us closer
because he's there to protect me
you know it's not it's not like it's not
like if we have an apartment where i
just leave her
by herself it's like if i leave her in
the streets
he's gotta know he's gonna always ask
somebody can you watch over even if
you're not with her just you know kind
of like because people
because i hear those crazy people and
they they like to get up you know she
she got raped um almost shaped them
almost raped we were sleeping uh
in russian vermont
and uh there's a little like cubby hole
thing this black guy came behind me and
stuck his dick up on my ass put his put
his dick on ass and almost did and then
my homie came out the car and saved the
life whatever but i was stuck i was
stuck in college park and he thinks it's
his fault it's not his fault i mean it
could have most likely wouldn't happen
when he if he was there but it's not his
fault you know what i mean
how's the the drug scene compare in
florida or vegas or here is it pretty
much the same everything no no no
florida you get a lot of free drugs free
cracks mainly because uh they want your
business yeah
uh
i remember i remember a couple times i'd
pull up to charles street in florida to
turn the beach in the car right a stone
car and uh the crack deals will put
their hands in the car with all the dope
and me and my friends just slap the
hands and the dope go in the car and we
peel off we got shot at and all that
stuff it was weird it was fun though i
don't know the funnest days of my life
on crack i think
uh because it was an adventure every day
was an adventure every day was like
actually gonna happen you know i don't
know if i was gonna live that i get shot
you know i mean
you know just an adrenaline rush you
know
and
i had some yeah
but now with fatty heads and
it's
i don't like it no more because every
time you know i want to spend time with
her she wants to sleep all the time you
know i mean and i'm like damn what's up
jay you know i don't know asleep it's
just
it's part of the drug you know but i
don't get like that
what do you guys say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
lives
uh the most important thing we learned
in our life
how to work together as a couple
yeah as a team in these streets because
all you guys each other and nobody else
is going to help you when [ __ ] goes
wrong you know
nobody nobody got our backs but that's
yeah
[Music]
all right
jessica and robert thank you so much for
sharing your stories
thank you stay safe out there hello i
hope you get housing
thank you
you